Look Who's Back
again
where have you been
all over all over yeah well you've been
in jail for a long time right yes and
then I just had a brief stint not the
cause of that Lobo I wasn't feeling too
good
so I checked myself in for a minute
um
you've been gone for a long time
it's been like eight or nine months I
think
I missed you I missed you more
I missed you too I really do the hardest
part was not knowing where you were
Rebecca I think about how frustrating it
must feel for you
what's that
just always giving and giving and yeah
what do you got out of a you know
I'm sure it really
really flusters you um
I'm used to it
same I'm tough
same mesh I'm glad to see you you just
got out of the hospital today yes I did
what is it like 10 o'clock
what time is that 10 o'clock
let me see 10 P.M
10 o'clock
how have you been is the question
mostly bored and frustrated I'm ready
take off your glasses Rebecca thank you
I'm fully ready to become a woman and
yet
there's some roadblocks in the way
I'm just really ready to commit to a
complete sex change a complete change in
general
I'm ready to elevate and Elevate those
that are that have been with me on this
journey and I apologize for being
a self-centered
good for nothing brought and I'm ready
to get to work on what needs doing and
this town needs fixing what happened to
Hollywood
it's not just old old Hollywood
glamorous they say about what happened
to the
you know
how old are you now 25 you're 25 yeah
one second cusp of that year so
hopefully I can go from
zero to here over well actually from
hero to zero but you know
and you're clean right now right
am I clean
well you've been in jail
or in the hospital for I suppose I'm
clean six seven eight months
is this the sober Rebecca I'm seeing
today
sober-minded Rebecca you're speaking
more slowly so that tells me that you're
at least semi-clean I'm just genuinely
flustered maybe right now
I feel like my future is up in arms so
to speak and
I'm ready to improve myself I'm ready to
put in the work
if the work is ready to receive me
I'd do anything to work with I do
anything to work for it
I think a new environment would probably
be good for you
that isn't Skid Row you mean that isn't
the streets that isn't skid row that
isn't even West Hollywood
having something that stimulated you
having some friends around some people
you connected with
could be very helpful
because you have nobody right you have
no friends
I do and I don't no but I mean real
friends
I'd love to have a friend or a co-worker
or anyone I know I'm not
I don't want to make an excuse about it
though
it's my fault
I'm very used to being alone right now
yeah you get used to it how many years
you've been living like this
no two maybe three years yeah that's
that's a long time you get used to
anything in two or three years
I think a new environment though
you know maybe a work environment
something you were stimulated by
could be great for you
I'm ready to stimulate underwear
stimulus the sun says
sorry I just feel very uh
numb right now
what were you in the hospital for
I was just feeling very depressed
I was thinking of ending my life
I don't really want to do that anymore
so I'm sorry for that was a real Act of
selfishness right there because I'm very
grateful for a lot of good
that is done for me a lot of good that
wants to come with me
no you have no idea the amount of
positivity you get from the viewers that
watch your videos on my channel
people are always really nice to me when
they meet me I think you're one of the
most loved uh interviewees on my channel
I think you've grown on everyone there
are videos of a lot of people but I
think you're everyone's favorite or a
favorite of a lot of people at least I
love you all more and back and whatever
it is that you want to see from me I
could be a show Pony
because that's what you desire
I just want you to be happy
I want you all to be happy I want to
satisfy you I want to cater to you
I want to be
Your Slave To Love
remember that's all I do believe
yeah I think more than anyone I've met
you have a tremendous amount of
potential Rebecca
thank you thank you as a friend as a
creative person as an artist is a you
have so much
I'm ready to do that now yeah I just
have to I have to make the first push
apparently I'm waiting my whole life for
someone to do it for me it'll take a
combination of things you probably need
a nice break from someone I mean I'll
take any opportunity that will come to
me well the the main thing in order to
keep that path open
would be to stay away from the drugs
it's not the drugs it's uh boredom
environment boredom yes it's the boredom
it's the boredom truly mm-hmm
and I'm a dancing with myself I know I'm
trying to revive uh
this dead notion of
grandeur
it's okay
I know it's okay as long as you're okay
I'm fine
I missed you I missed you too I miss you
I wouldn't say more but I missed you too
we just haven't spent enough time
together we're missing more you know
what I mean I know but if we could
actually socialize it's just you always
seem so frustrated I'm very elusive
no but when you're super high I just
can't spend much time with you
why because you make me crazy why you're
just so chaotic and out of control you
you take over the entire
interaction
you're like a tornado you're like the
Tasmanian devil and I can't have a
thought to myself because you're just so
out of control
and that's always when you're super high
yeah it's just because I don't know I
tend to it's a habit of member I've
always been that way it's like you're
gonna go into someone's house and you
kind of like raid their fridge and I'm
ready to stop doing that I'm ready to
like bow down in gratitude to everyone
and everything
I'm ready to take that slice of humble
Cherry Pie and see if it'll have me back
because I'm so grateful and I love you
all and I love it all so much
I love it all too much to just let it go
I threw it all away I don't know why
well I do know why it knows to spread it
then I'm not blaming you for it but but
you're it's your lack of
Community a lack of stimulation
Community I I need all that desperately
yeah it was as I was dropping down here
to meet you I was thinking like what
does Rebecca need thank you for coming
by the way thank you why you know I
think what Rebecca needs
is
a friend
maybe maybe a few solid friends and a
place to look forward to going every
morning like a job sure yes a career I
just really
think all my problems will be solved
when I transition
you think that's the answer
I know it's the answer what would you
rather have what would you rather have
a sex change
or a career
that you're into that is challenging and
stimulating
we both would come into each other no no
but you can only have one or the other
which one would you want
both
all right
you win when you smoke you don't you
don't talk while you smoke you inhale
and exhale
so I don't get the whole sex change
thing
no but I look at you
and your your what do you call it a CIS
male is that what it's called you're a
male you have something between your
legs like I do I know which I'm ready to
chop off you said too much blood I just
see you as a super interesting male with
a lot of talent and potential then you
haven't seen me properly as a woman
because I haven't properly expressed
that truly
I think as a man I'm impish and weak and
I make excuses as a woman
I'm very defensive I think of my
femininity or of my ways
I think honestly all I've been doing is
just the beginning of nymphomaniac when
uh the mother is playing her deck of
cards as the two little girls are
playing LeapFrog in the tub or whatever
that's what I feel like right now
I love Joe
she's incredible Shadows guys will
played her really well I'm sorry she
reminds me the goddess of Persephone
who's that Persephone the goddess
she's uh the devil's daughter or is
misinterpreted as the wife
perception
can you imagine
so I wonder when Demeter delivers her
I suppose should be delivered
so it has to begin
a girl I was at a club and she said her
name was Persephone or she said
Persephone she's like why don't you have
an EBT card am I
I don't eat
sleep or drink
as a woman
with that little boy inside of me
he's gonna grow up to be something way
bigger than we anticipated
I just hope that I'm deserving of
my role and
this experience
you are
I'm very sorry no I have to apologize
okay I've been a lazy good for nothing
bum and I'm sorry no but it's up to you
to change that and if you did I can
guarantee you everyone would forgive you
in a second exactly so can we get me in
touch with uh
I don't know
a doctor the state department
so anything to solidify me as an
American woman because that's what I
feel I am I'm an American woman I've
heard the state of California makes it
easy
does it yeah I think so
I was loved if they did
X Madame X
this name McDonald's I saw have you ever
seen that uh portrait Madame X
I think it was John Singer sergeant if
it's in there I don't know reminds me my
friend Evelyn
North Dakota Johnson's gonna be uh
she's doing Marvel Now Madame web
remember I was in uh Venice once and um
I can guarantee you it would take
everyone about half a second to forgive
you sometimes you're caught in a web of
life that's true
do you really want to make me cry
I'm shaking in my boots
the potential that our future has for us
I think the thing to remember here is
that you're very young am I am I you are
can I accept that
it's up to you but you are very I feel
like a more inexperienced than I am
Young
25 your understanding of fashion popular
culture is impressive very untrue
I can speak understanding of like
culture and there's a few thousand
people that have cried before you I get
people I understand people I know how to
cater
to people's desires
it's like Jennifer Lynn said you want to
you want to know what people want
before they want it
it's a great skill I think what you want
from me is a pariah should I be crying I
really want to cry
you haven't cried here yet
you haven't given me the
space to cry yes I have
three make him cry
make me cry
tell me about your mom
which one
the one I just showed you the photo of
oh birth mother
I'm
grateful for the responsibility that I
got from that
to love myself
poor her
when's the last time you talked to her
oh it's been years that photo of you
with her was probably when you were a
teenager right
nine what nine eight nine
you look much older
I always got thought
heal my vape you probably had a full
beard at nine years old
not by the hours on my channel
I don't want to be a man anymore
I just don't know how to take the first
step
I went to a clinic and they were like oh
you need a
you need to like
apply for insurance or something like
that I'm like yeah I don't know nothing
bro yeah right insurance I think that's
how it works I think I'm trying to give
out the insurance that I will be
everything for all of you
make you all like stars or diamonds or
just grateful to have me around
everyone's grateful to have you around
I'm grateful for everyone for every
single last person
I really am
no but if you were serious about having
that surgery which I don't understand
but I am very serious about it okay okay
okay then I'm just gonna play along
because that's what you say you want
you're not gonna be able to walk into an
office and get that surgery while you're
high as a kite no one's going to be like
sign here and we'll do it
you understand
sign here no when you're in that frame
of mind oh isn't there a deal you can
make in this town no nobody including me
is going to say sure because you're
you're too high what happened to
Hollywood baby sex drugs rock and roll
what happened to all that so I went
green are you sure 1984 really
are we really gonna compromise
see this wife should have been born in
the 80s I should have done this in the
80s yeah but when you tell me you want a
sex change and you're in this frame of
mind
it's a sex change but is that a woman to
you
sobering I'm sorry there are bad girls
out there you know what I mean
who can have it all have your cake and
eat it too
let them eat cake
you know they serve it done with the
mission every day huge cakes
huge cakes
I didn't know I've never read in there
never even been down there I've been
there have you been inside yeah I have
what did you think of it I haven't been
inside I was impressed right how
professional it all was they put out a
nice spread for everybody
put on a nice spread Ashton Kutcher
this ping pong however
ah
love sex or marriage big one
love
love
see I usually go with sex or marriage
because love is innate you know what I
mean
sex is aggressive marriage is a default
to me
I prefer marriage actually
I think I think being married to someone
you don't love would be horrible
no if you're married to someone you love
them de facto you wouldn't raise one if
you didn't love him or love there no
you're right and if you love someone's
assets you love their taste if you love
their taste then you must know if you
love somebody marriage very often
follows Nicole Smith really did kiss him
you know what I mean sure they kiss him
on the lips
you think Anna Nicole Smith I love her
loved your husband
actually I've
she probably did
people love to be judgmental about those
kind of relationships but I'm looking
behind any younger woman she was he was
very old and Wealthy she was very young
and you know sexy I guess
I'll bet you they had some
I mean he knew exactly what he was doing
and so did she they both understood each
other and I'll bet I'll bet they had a
good time have you ever seen that movie
The Disappearance of Alma Rigby
I can just adjusting his fabulous I met
her I remember her I met her and she was
wearing shades
I think I shook her hand or something
I don't Missy Pyle too
she was in now
it was Alexander she was in Stormbreaker
celebrity
I love celebrity I know you do you know
I do who's your favorite celebrity
this week
celebrity or famous person
celebrity
same thing
see I would always who's your favorite
person who's my favorite person
foreign
people Mary Kate Olsen Ashley Olsen
Rachel Zell
you mentioned them a lot
apparently I do
I'm trying to ensure that we keep their
name up there where it belongs
it's been a couple years now and you're
still
enamored with with them
those women very true and that says a
lot about your
consistency and
I suppose
I guess you don't you don't change your
opinion every week
like some girls
opinion
ah
I just have to apologize for completely
having wasted so much time and I'm ready
to get back into the grind of it
but I'm sorry
are you gonna get high tonight
now that you're free on the streets
again
uh
can you take off the glasses please
are you gonna get high tonight
are you gonna get high tonight I'm not
going to get high tonight
well then I suppose I'll get low
would rather I slit my throat or stunt
my wrists
neither no be honest neither I'm an
intolerable human being
I'm an intolerable human being no you're
not you can talk about cruelty you ever
see that one see what I've learned after
all these interviews doing all these
talks is
the issue that we really need to talk
about instead of drugs instead of mental
health I mean sometimes it's a chemical
imbalance and that's that's a different
story but
but the real issue behind almost every
one of these talks is
self-worth true because if you don't
believe you deserve all the things
you've talked about
which is really just happiness and
fulfillment you're not going to allow it
to happen
you're not going to do what's required
for it to happen you're not going to
accept it if it falls into your lap I'm
ready to do that
I'm just waiting for what is it not the
other the other Shooters just because
you want it doesn't mean you believe you
deserve it I know I do believe I deserve
it Everybody Wants To Be A Millionaire
but it's wrong for me to say I'm selfish
in this context for some reason even
though I spend all my time alone
but selfishness is such a non-asset to
me in my life
and this debacle is back and forth as to
what my fate will be
I think other people need to feel
deserved of the sort of experience that
I would provide
Sasha Gray it's a girlfriend experience
Stephen Soderberg was it 2011 or 2013
2013. 2013 was an interesting year
2022
I have high hopes for 2023.
in 2024
and then 2026 and we're all done with
our mission statement
I know some guy who just died it's okay
we're joined to be in five years
W magazine
Vero
as a consultant
um I'd also like to maybe creative
direct something some clubs or maybe
theater
something to do with movement so maybe
dance bring dance more to the Forefront
in New York or L.A
both
but when you said New York something
just ticked you know what I mean
I can't wait to get back to New York
properly but I need to stay here in L.A
because you seem like a New York person
to me I'm very much a New York person
although when I was in New York I was
scared shitless I don't know it's kind
of like Chicken Little I went to a
really weird Harmony experience but
being scared like that is a compass
telling you what you should be doing
that's so true
I'm just afraid of it's not not making
it
it's that other people would hinder me
making it so if any opportunity were to
open its doors but I may be like yes of
course I wouldn't deny it
but I mean I didn't go to college
no matter what I'll never have a period
so
I'll never fully be the woman that they
are
you're still cute you're actually more
adorable adorable you're adorable when
you're adorable off the drugs what a
little [ __ ] puppy Pawn
do you create a bun and laughter and um
Chrome hearts
when was the last time you ever really
fell in love
um probably about seven years ago
no no no seven plus five so
is that 12 years real love yeah 12. 12.
yeah 12 years
I've fallen in love a few times
my wife was a great one
My First Girlfriend was great
no it's it's the most magical [ __ ] on
Earth I'd love to be a wife you know
I've never even been on a date
I really am like a virgin I'd love to
meet love or find love
and to give it back
and forth
real love not that schmalty sticky [ __ ]
but like real
tiger you've been in love before
yes yes I have
uh let's just say three men and um of
them all Zinnia dalido always gets the
fourth so we're waiting on number four
three men who equally and dignifiedly
Bash themselves in public at my uh
at the behest of Maya
undoing
a caesar salad
a pizza
and some olives
Caesar Brutus and Marc Anthony
but my heart wasn't for them my heart
belongs to Daddy so wherever Daddy is
Mr and Mrs ax I would say
yeah
tragic I know tragic but he's somewhere
out there my soul mate I can feel it
there's a saying
that goes uh it's better to love than be
loved
what do you think of that
is it yeah true yeah yeah I mean there's
no there's no comparison
some of them want to it beautiful
some of them want to be abused
I don't want to be abused I don't want
to feel pain
and I'd love to introduce to Human
Society the idea that pain can be
removed
it's science nerves you find the nerve
that produces the pain
and you revert it
and you're done
shout out to Alaska 5000 Oscar
[ __ ] NGA gun by the way I'm sorry
oh there are two drag queens that I love
in the door who who are they we're
having a little Turf War I see
where are they who are they oh who are
they Alaska thunderfucker 5000 it was
one of the AAA girls I'm sorry you're
speaking so quickly I can't oh she's uh
she's like a bird of prey or like a bird
of paradise she's incredible I love it
what's your name again Alaska
[ __ ] Oscar 5000. Alaska Alaska
may I ask you a question yes Alaska
Alaska [ __ ] Alaska is in but
anyway as in snow ice NGO gun like the
studio right here
just do it right above the red line
really yeah if you're caught by her you
little boy
you little boy
I'm not hip on that whole Community I'm
sorry it's called Bangkok now bangkan
I I would love to read too I wonder if
they'll ever accept me as one of theirs
I'd love to be a drag queen or a
transvestite
or a transgender woman in Hollywood
America
I don't want to be a bum [ __ ] little
boy anymore
well it seems like there are now so many
I just young men that are blurring the
lines between male and female does that
work for you or you want to be a
full-out female I want to be a full-on
woman female scientific term woman woman
I'd love to be a woman I'm not a girl
not yet a woman but I'd love to be a
woman
massage Davis said it herself takes a
lot of balls to be a woman
True Grit I'm not [ __ ] about this has
always been your desire yes since you
were six years old yes but I didn't know
it you know what I mean yeah at that age
you don't know anything yeah it's the
duality of things I I didn't even think
I was gay I was doing fashion it was
just fashion everything else is like
whatever Love Sex Magic
what magic you know
we were talking about witchcraft earlier
so
MC is finally doing a dual show all the
all of them witches and uh The Witches
of Mayfair which is a lot about where we
are in a society because honestly there
is not one great movie other than
Suspiria that gives us a strong powerful
woman which even the craft you know what
I mean there's a sense to me either like
it's it's hard to to be evil my empathy
goes towards the evil people in life
because to be evil not just the heart of
gold but to be evil
it just it's just to be self-tolerant of
pain
it's like good for Kim Kardashian that's
very well done could be darker but good
for her good for her you know it's kind
of like Paris or Nikki helped him who I
think is
if anyone if I'm gonna recommend one
interview in life because I don't like
watching interviews and I get bored she
did an interview with W magazine just
before just after her marriage
and she's very succinct at
like you said deserving
because that was the one social I
thought everyone was like ooh she's
paris's hanger on she's she got married
and uh
Kensington Palace
it's a big a few to society you know
what I mean
no offense to Paris who I adore more
than anything
but she caught her the big fish and I
was thinking Hilton Rothschild
good for her she didn't abuse it in any
way
but for the first time I saw her go to
the Vanity Fair Oscar party
so you know
it's kind of like that congratulations
sex tape of society
an F you to society
why bother
I'm gonna try to step on anyone's Toes
or anything
I tried very carefully people don't know
this about me
I'm too careful I wish I could be more
Reckless but that's why I spent my time
alone what do people not know about
Rebecca
um
give me an example we just assume you're
wild and crazy and very creative
I don't understand these are things
you're saying to me but you know thank
you no but but there are things that I'm
very vulnerable I don't mind being
insulted by people but I can be very
vulnerable
and I tend to give it away as an asset
like use my weakness or my Frailty to
their advantage to get out of a
situation
whether being a doctor you know what I
mean if the other day some guy tried to
like attack me on the outskirts of West
Hollywood Hollywood and I just kind of
like did nothing because I couldn't
physically push him off me that's why I
felt like of complete failure as a human
being especially as a woman I felt like
how dare I
he didn't even feel like I didn't but I
just like let him attack me so I could
just get away
rather than you're not a fighter I'd
love to be but you know some people are
just not meant to fight I'm like three
pounds soaking wet oh no I'd love to
fight
I'd love to fight and I know how to do
it succinctly I know how to
punch lines are always really good
humor humor no humor if you're intellect
in your sense of humor the last book I
read what was the last book I read
impressive kind of thing you can fight
with your mind baby
May the force
be with
but you know I like it rough oh
I'm just ready to get rid of using my
guilt and shame as some kind of a pawn
in The Game of Life
here I am begging you America
begging you for what
is the right to become an American woman
will America grant me that wish you're
more focused on becoming a woman
than getting your life or career
together they're all the same thing they
all come together they would yes they
would okay I understand that
I can't understand the sex change but if
I can get over that hurdle yeah but
there are no women in syndrome you
haven't seen me around women when I'm
around women it becomes more apparent I
just have to really act this way sorry
excuse the beard
um thank you again Mrs kosher Davis
that's what they call them right
beards the wife of a dude or the
girlfriend of a dude who's in the dude
their beard I'm trying to imagine
if you were taking the female female
hormones yes I would maybe you know your
voice would change
it's not just that your beard would
probably disappear well all of this
would be vastly improved by me becoming
a woman I'm thinking making the excuses
just honestly I went to the trans
Wellness Center they told me that I had
to wait three weeks to get it
approval for Medicare which is almost up
yeah but if you're serious about that
I'm very serious about that the way to
go about it
is to walk into these offices with a
clear head and the ability to fill out a
form and stay seated for half an hour or
so and to get through an interview so
they can see that you're mentally stable
I'd love to do that
exactly in the right mind which I am
which you are right now but if I leave
you alone tonight tomorrow you're going
to be high as a kite
and you're not going to be able to do
anything I will trust me I will
you will what get high no I will
I fully commit to the transition take
off your glasses please I fully commit
to the transition no I understand you
commit to the church that's easy to say
I I want to do it I just genuinely I'm
not very good at resources and hunting
things down I don't even have a phone no
I get it but but what happens is you get
bored you get bored you get lonely on
the loneliness and then you need to get
high to distract yourself from the no my
life has a double situation it can be
very
fun and it can be very dark at times and
when it's dark I tend to actually lay
low and hide and stay sober and do
nothing and lay on the side of the road
like [ __ ] doing nothing and eating
trash Pizza
the [ __ ] that's the boy in me
a little little Roman do you appreciate
good food
I appreciate good company yes yes I do I
do and my surroundings and good people
good energy better vibes Hollywood baby
you seem like the type of person that
would appreciate these things
but then on the other hand you seem
content with living on the street like a
rat yeah like Danielle bregoli before me
but I don't look like a rock kind of
like a monkey dog
you walk around shoeless half the time
yeah I know right that's going to become
my calling card apparently and you're
wearing a piece of fabric as a dress
so so is that Drake phone you ended up
in jail for indecent exposure yeah but I
put on a skirt underneath it's a white
T-shirt yeah I see that the perfect
plain white tee you know what I thought
happened is so you ended up in jail for
in decent exposure is that right maybe
two and a half that's all yeah that's
all it seemed to be all summer you were
gone all summer I was gone no I got in a
day before my birthday or two days
before my birthday when's your birthday
August 4th yeah so from Summer till so
from August 3rd or August 2nd
through fall and now we're in winter and
spring and I know you're in there for
indecent exposure which I believe is a
sex offense so that means you need to
register and I thought maybe you didn't
register so maybe you got in trouble
because oh no no I didn't get that you
didn't get that and I didn't eat
directions I'm not a sex offender okay
I'm not sex in Asia so
no but walking around naked will get you
a sex offense
well then close close baby
how many far from heaven and then you
know sin look there was a parable of
2022 that's Duality see but we're in
2023 now so either way and the reality
shifted to a great platonic stoich the
menu Avatar
the way of water walk onto forever
those are the three uh Temple you know
they call them Temple films of this
season which is a lot about the unique
theater does it say a lot about me I
don't know it's not like I'm the one
running Hollywood
we're almost there too with Angeline
biopic but I mean you're awesome why
would you cost her
such a
such a Mary Kate move but anyway good
for her out of Casper candy as Angeline
but you know
I love Brooklyn do you know Brooke Candy
I don't
she's a rapper she's an artist rapper
she's like I want things to Boom for her
like she deserves so much more
she could have been like the Kylie
Jenner of Rob because of Stephen Klein
but you know but she chose herself again
her record maybe didn't sell as much as
she wanted to but she just went in it
for the process of becoming a star
age of a wheelchair handy
what do you make of this new world we
have
this we have a whole new world at our
fingertips we can do whatever we want
now
the whole social media celebrity thing
is is so crazy is it I feel like um
they call them influencers mark and
Ashley Olsen influence coffee table book
a little bird told me that they might
have used it to get him to Parsons
School of Design
or fit
but I mean the best of them always drop
out for a semester all to Zara Alexander
Wang
Brooke Candy
Brooke Candy
anyway this is me welcome to me Kristen
Wiig 2014. you should watch that movie
mark
if you want to tell the story of that
movie
welcome to me
so this crazy girl joins the lottery
like Powerball 100 million
she sometimes as infomercials
and uh she said she wants to have her
own talk show
she comes in on a beautiful swan
[Music]
remember we were watching that clip from
Black Swan
I love Winona Ryder
she should have won the Oscar
no offense to it no the appointment
should have won it for jockey I mean her
portrayal and blacks I'm going crazy oh
you know I thought oh it ain't over to
the fact that he said exception I think
Winona Ryder should have won it and
she's the one for jockey
Hollywood baby here
what would I do for love
welcome Barefoot picking up cigarette
butts smoking my girls out of tar pets
for the one I love
tar and feathers
tar and Roses I still have an unpaid
chocolate torn roses in Venice
so thank you honestly mostly to the
police department for being very lenient
with my behavior sometimes are shopping
the police are nice to you oh they're
very nice to me they're so good to me
remember the one time that I got almost
like detained here for a second the
officially gave me his Big Mac it
started Egg McMuffin because I said I
was hungry that's so nice yeah that was
so nice to me no I have nothing against
the police I love Metropolitan Place not
super showers these are Skid Row or West
Hollywood Police oh West Hollywood
Police um well because that's also a
chair's apartment not let's call the
police what's Hollywood Police there's
about three or four of them I know
exactly who they are and they're all men
and I just don't appreciate being in
West Hollywood and being told that um
ironic Sirens because what's how we
think you would identify as whatever
however you want being told explicitly
no you're a man I'm like no I'm woman
you know my pockets come up or whatever
how I was raised
I definitely want a fresh start so my
name is Rebecca Rebecca Olson and
Rebecca Olson so I prefer it that way
and I'll model myself after I'm like
Marilyn Manson
he took mail in from Monroe and Madison
from Charles
I got Olson from the office of twins I
got Zoe from Rachel Zoe and Rebecca
well she'll always be back for more
using the movie 13.
with Evan Rachel Wood and Nikki Reed I
have it I mean
and actually puzzle on their tongue in
the poster so you know drugs hugs
jugs
not pugs
not mugs
no you're beautiful
no no you're beautiful you're you're
beautiful I'm ugly no no no relax I'm
ugly I'm okay with it you're not ugly
you're beautiful okay you're beautiful
inside I know
I'm a work in progress you're beautiful
see that's the self-worth that you're
struggling with it's okay to be ugly
what I've been on a date my whole life
I'm gonna wrestling on a date
I can't even get late it's probably
because I'm homeless in my foot like an
idiot but you know
I like that I'm skinny and I like my
lips and I like my eyes
I hate my nose
I hate my nose
I wish I had a more cinched in stomach
so I guess maybe if I which I never got
breast implants but once I start taking
my hormones I would presume that I got
that hourglass figure
I like my body
but I don't like my ribs I like my rib
cage I think my nipples are too small I
hate my feet my feet are my biggest
thing my feet my nose so I want to get a
foot job and a nose job a foot job with
a foot job I want to get my feet
decreased by like three four sizes but
try back come on to wear heels no really
I'm like a size 10 11 12.
make your feet small I definitely would
well that's all I do apparently is
sit around with my feet all day but
anyway
I just love to be a celebrity Mark oh
you've already made a star of me how can
we capitalize on that no no what do I do
with you tonight I know get me to a
talent agent
I can think I can dance I can act
I'm very opinionated
make me a star Mark you already kind of
have I think I already have so many
people in the city know who I am like oh
hi Rebecca I'm like
hi I never know what to say because
people are so mean in the comments
always assume it's like oh look it's
around oh my God not you
not anymore not anymore I haven't read
the comments I haven't even seen the
videos I'll have a tablet that I should
charge someone gave me that tablet today
for my um
the flower I can do it in the morning
it'll be true in the morning
in the morning
what I need is a phone a gun I know I'll
get you another phone are you gonna
really I love you more thank you but
you're gonna lose it [ __ ] you Mark I
love you I'm not gonna lose that every
phone I've given you how about if you
give me a phone and we and you drive
into a clinic because I know the clinic
is called the trans Wellness Center
and we legitimize mice exchange and get
me a place to stay
and if you need an assistant I'll work
with you or if you can help me get a job
and I'll work for you for tips literally
maybe somebody will offer you a job that
would be nice wouldn't that be great
wouldn't that be great I'd love to look
at flaunt there's a magazine in
Hollywood called flaunt and they're
perfectly like not mid-low level but
like they're not in the fashion like in
the fashion Spectrum they're not like
they're not Vogue but I want to make
them into like the LA West Coast Vogue
it's kind of like ID about the same and
I'd love to just intern there
I mean Robert De Niro did it in a movie
right he was like some old dude or
whatever
it's like fashion I didn't think you'd
need a college education for fashion
but I'm just ready willing able to do it
it's just honestly I'm a bit of a
princess and a bit of a broad and I like
things my way but with fashion I've
learned that yeah no I can assimilate
very well that's all
right
you don't really have a good resume
right now I assume I don't have a resume
I haven't worked my resume what is my
resume homeless Skid Row this video I'm
trying to these videos on my channel are
you are my resume yes it's a disaster
who would ever hire that
you got to take a leap of faith
that I would do
I've done that with people a lot
I'm all yours Mr DeMille
if you'll have me
yeah
I've heard photos I'm sorry favorite of
all time favorite of anything because
what a million Griffith she just won the
Oscar right or whatever and she's the on
a hotel is just sitting on top of a limo
smoking a cigarette holding the Oscar I
think earliest you know I love Melanie
Griffith such a shame what happened to
her they're trying to make a movie about
lions or lions for like a decade in
their house and then their face got all
screwed up I think she's so beautiful
though she looks like Renaissance and I
love her daughter Dakota Johnson
although she doesn't look like her at
all she doesn't look like Don Johnson
either but whatever I love Dakota
Johnson she was in that movie Suspiria I
think she was great clear guys
that's three that's three witches
Golden Rule
so that's 26 will be the new 25. so I'm
on the other class of 25.
I'm ready to
no not there
pop ate my heart he downed it down in
one efficient cult I want more
I want the future
fashion technology
I want the fame the fame
the fame
Rebecca thank you very much very much
for Staying Alive you really are the
Mark Wahlberg to my Kate Moss
because that was her column she was in
the Calvin Klein uh ad with Mark
Wahlberg it's kind of awkward between
them but like we took like all that for
each other you know we're an Odd Couple
that's for sure we definitely aren't our
couple meeting you mark
my lover
[Music]
yeah don't tell anybody I won't tell
anyone not a soul your secrets are safe
with my PP oh God oh God all right
Rebecca I'm glad whenever we got that
hot [ __ ] ready you know let me figure
out what I'm gonna do with you tonight
what are you gonna do with me tonight oh
Mark Mark please please it's been years
I'm glad you're okay great seeing you
again saving it for marriage XOXO
Gotham girl